consciousness can exist independent of  what created the consciousness in the  first place whether that consciousness  goes on to another place you know we can  all read the books about the monroe  institute for instance you know this  notion that there's people have  out-of-body experiences have you ever  had one i had one i remember uh waking  up and i was in the middle of nowhere  like stars and i go oh my god i'm in  space how am i going to get home then  there was like one star  that was brighter than all of the others  i said oh that must be my star i just  felt this rushing feeling and i  literally remember coming down through  the trees through the roof and then into  me then i woke up it could be just a  dream but it's the most unusual dream  that i ever had that had a sense of  reality i mean most dreams i forget well  that sounds like maybe like an astral  projection i don't know what it was but  i found it fascinating